so let's bring in retired lieutenant
lieutenant general keith kellogg former
national security adviser to vice
president mike pence uh good to have you
with us today general kellogg i want to
start by playing this from anthony
blinken about where they see the moves
uh from putin materializing right now
watch this
everything that we're seeing including
what you've described in the last
24-48 hours
is part of
a scenario that is already in play of
creating uh false provocations
of then having to respond
to those provocations and then
ultimately
um
committing new aggression against
ukraine yeah so the russians have pulled
out evacuated all the men and i mean the
women and children from the donbass
region which they have a rebel hold on
essentially it's just a big chunk of
ukraine um they have said that ukraine
is about to attack that area
how do you assess where we are now
general
yeah look uh thanks mark thanks for
having me look i think we're heading to
a gunfight uh what i mean by that
between ukraine and russia it's pretty
clear to me with the array of forces
that putin has around ukraine he's got
over 70 percent of his army
located around ukraine right now and
he's brought forces in from the far east
as well look we're talking past each
other and and i think the time for
diplomacy is is pretty well gone here's
what i mean we keep talking about nato
nato nato putin knows that putin has
said repeatedly he has no intention of
engaging nato he knows it's a
suicidal event if he does so it in fact
he knows it's the end of russia if he
does that so he's not going to get
anywhere close to nato he doesn't really
care about nato right now because nato
has already said ukraine is not part of
nato
article 5 an attack on one an attack on
all
doesn't apply to nato so he knows he's
got a he's got a
free card to go forward
president biden gave him one when he
said well a limited incursion might be
okay president biden also said no issue
u.s troops are going to go into ukraine
so this has left ukraine
wide open and i think the diplomacy is
gone and i think you're heading down the
path that uh putin is going to go in in
a military
invasion here's the problem i've got
martha
it's easy to get into a fight it's
really hard to get out of one so the
next question ought to be in everybody's
mind senior decision makers okay how do
you stop this fight how do you end it
in a way that's acceptable to the west
as well as for russia because russia is
going to be the occupier
yeah well that's a great question i
heard general keen earlier saying that
he doesn't believe that president
zielenski of the ukraine of ukraine
should be going to this munich security
uh conference in the coming days he said
it is probably not a good idea given
russia's posture for him to be out of
the country do you agree
oh yeah i mean
general king was right he leaves the
country he's not coming back in i mean
if they start an invasion in the next
two days
there's no way he's getting back into
ukraine unless it's on foot in the
middle of the night
because they'll control all of the air
space you know and this is not a small
fight russia is the largest country in
europe and also the european and asia
air land mass ukraine's the second
largest country in europe this year two
large countries potentially involved in
conflict not part of nato so natives can
have to sit on and sit on the sidelines
and watch this thing go because there's
no recourse for them to do anything
about it that's what i mean about
talking past each other there has been
ways we probably could have worked this
but both sides were intransigent in
their positions and nobody worked
towards the middle ground that's my
frustration because you know diploma
diplomacy is sometimes hard and you
don't get everything you want you may go
to an eighty percent solution on each
side but but both sides wanted to have a
hundred percent and they wanted to go
their way and i think because of that
and the hardcore positions both sides
have taken i think you're heading to a
fight well we know from everything that
vladimir putin has said really since
about 2007 that he does not believe in
the security architecture of the
post-cold war period he doesn't buy it
he doesn't buy the united states as the
lead superpower
he wants to rearrange that architecture
and that is the goal that he's working
towards so we'll see where this goes
general kellogg thank you very much
great to have you with us today sir